And they found a seal and they said this
is Shiva because uh he has horns and
three faces and he's covered with
jewelry. And then his uh feet as you can
see are boine feet. Bovine cow like veil
or something. Yeah. And then uh there's
also goat with long horns. So when a
person is practicing yoga, they are
linking their mind with Shiva's mind.
Wow. All yoga gurus who have been
trained you know they call RIT
registered yoga teacher um 300 or 500
that is basically 300 hours or 500 hours
um so they all would know Patanjali
and he is called as the author of all
yoga principles. Now when we when
somebody wants to look into the life of
this character called Patanjali
who is the author of all of the yoga uh
principles whether it is meditation or
stretching and all of that people's
people attributed to Patanjali.
But who is Patanjali?
Generally in Hindu uh websites uh they
state that he lived around 2,000 years
ago or 1,500 years ago or 2500 years ago
approximately and nobody really knows
where exactly he lived. However, who was
he?
When we look into who was Pateli,
it tells uh one of the Hindu website
tells that um he was an ancient serpent.
H
I heard this story before. Yeah. Right.
So Adi Sa means serpent. Adi means
ancient. Ancient serpent. Not only that,
he has another name as well. And uh he's
also called as a wise anantasa. Ananta
means wisdom.
So basically Patanjali is ancient wise
serpent. Wow. Wow. And he wrote the
principles of yoga that everybody
practiced today. It's like there's like
one story and they just keep finding
different angles to tell the one story
to all the different cultures. I mean,
that's fascinating. I'm surprised it's
not any older than 2,000 years ago. H I
think it would be older than that. Yeah.
But uh we're going to come we're going
to talk about one more character
who was more ancient than Patanjali.
We're getting to that few slides. The
truth really will set you free. And as
Christians, we have um an advantage cuz
imagine if you just never heard the
Bible ever. Yeah. And you hear, well,
all around the world, people worship
serpents and there's this crown, you
know, this serpent that needs to go to
my crown chakra. and and all you hear is
this one angle that he's wise, that he
wants to open your eyes. He wants to
give you wisdom. He tells you you're
like God. Then that's going to look like
this is the truth because you hear it
all around. It's in cultures everywhere.
But we have the Bible that says, "No, he
was the one that deceived humanity and
that's why we're in this big mess and
yet the whole world will worship him."
You know, it says that the the dragon,
that old serpent deceives the whole
world and yet we see it right there. So
was
was condundalini
uh yoga like one of the first kinds
because of his association with a
serpent or was that that serpent piece
kind of all there from the beginning?
So the serpent piece was uh always there
from the beginning. Uh but even before
that the primary um
name associated to yoga is Shiva
and we're going to look into who is
Shiva. The destroyer. Yeah. The
destroyer. Yeah. Mhm. So there's a
serpent around his neck and uh so
wherever there is uh Shiva except for
certain forms but most of the forms of
Shiva there's always a serpent
especially a cobra not just any serpent
not like a rattlesnake
cobra why why the cobra just it's the
king of the snakes because it is the
most wisest of the serpent species
according to science so from whom did
yoga originate
Lord Shiva Ah says a quote among the
great deities of Hinduism most
personifies the practice of yoga as
yogeshwara the great lord of yoga adi
yogi and maha yogi he rules over all
aspects of yoga relative to body which
is stretching mind and consciousness for
those looking to understand the origins
of yoga and the role of all yoga
practices within it they must first look
to Lord Shiva wow not only related to
historical teachings but as eternal
presence of yoga, the supreme
consciousness behind the universe. See,
that's what I'm saying by you can't just
take that and ascribe that to God.
That's not what they're saying that
that's connection is. Yeah. Then
according to Hindu philosophy, Lord
Shiva, the source of yoga, danced the
world into existence and gave it order.
The universe is thus viewed as Nataraja,
the cosmic dance of Shiva. Because of
the new age teachings that has entered
into Christianity when Christians say
that okay talk to God talk to universe
talk to the Lord talk to universe that
is so wrong in many levels because
universe is not God it's not Jesus
Christ universe is Shiva so you're going
to say who this is what he's standing
yes yes so um so this is a form of Shiva
uh it's called nataraja And he's called
as Nataraja in this form. Nataraja means
lot of dance and acting and drama. And
uh music also evolved from him they say.
Oh interesting. Yes. You always hear
that Lucifer was like the chief of music
that his whole body was made up out of
instruments. Yeah.
So some u people say this is a male
child. Yeah. And then some of them say
it's not a male child. It is a demon of
ignorance. And Shiva is a god of
knowledge. And so he's crushing the male
child. Do you ring a bell? Male child.
Mhm. Male child. It's like Jesus. Yeah.
And which is which is really kind of a
reversal of the um prophecy in the
Garden of Eden that you know Yeah. it
would bite the heel and Yes. the heel
would crush. Yes. It's a reverse. Yeah.
Wow. It's a reverse. Wow. This is
interesting. I know. I never I never saw
that. I seen the statue a million times
but did not know the details of that.
Neither. That is fascinating. I didn't
even know knew the details of it. I've
seen that as well. All my life I've seen
it. Uh it's uh any Indian um Hindu owned
restaurant will have a statue. Oh yeah.
In the US or anywhere in the world
because this is the most popular form of
Shiva. M what are some other forms
besides the serpent and this form? Oh
okay. So there is uh there are many
forms. He has many many forms. Uh
there's a form called as duana morti in
in Sanskrit language. Duana means south
facing. Morti means teacher.
And uh you know viewers can actually if
you can you know Google you can find
Dakshina Morti uh I think it is D A K S
H N as a Nancy A M U R T H Y or M U R T
H I and then you will see in in
Wikipedia you will see the picture of
him from a temp at a temple where he's
seated under tree of knowledge. Whoa.
What's with the crossing of the leg?
Does that have some significance? Yes.
So, one is uh male, the other one is
female side. Oh. Half male and half uh
half woman, half male. Got it.
Yeah. So, the Dina Morti
he is a teacher that teaches under the
tree of knowledge. Wow. And uh even at
that uh at his feet there, there is a
male. Mhm. is blue blue in the picture.
Yeah. Yeah. And most of those temples of
dakshina morti form of Shiva, they are
built facing the south because he's a
south facing teacher. In other words,
the devotees have to face the sides of
the north. Oh, okay.
I will send the sides of the north.
Yeah. Yeah. Above the clouds. Yeah. I'll
be like the most high. Yes.
You see the parallels a lot of so when a
person is practicing yoga they are
linking their mind with Shiva's mind.
Wow.
And obviously the destroyer I mean it's
so opposite than God right I've come to
give them life that they may have it
more abundantly. It's the opposite of
destruction and ruining them you know.
Yeah. And he's the creator. But Shiva
supposedly created out of chaos which is
also taught in
science order out of chaos bang
explosion but yet it's a perfect
beautiful creation whereas god he spoke
it he spoke it and it became because he
is the truth everything he speaks comes
to existence so I just want to go back
to the dakshina morti part so anyway so
so devotees have to worship him facing
the sides of the north so that's one
form and then uh Another form is um he's
also an alien because he does not belong
to the human race. Whereas Christ
belongs to the human race. Mhm. He
became son of man. When he's coming back
second time, second advent, he's called
a son of man. And he calls he he says
that he is our brother. Yeah. So Shiva
does not say that. To my knowledge, he's
never said I'm your brother. Mhm. So he
is a not of the human race
and um he's also called as a universe.
He's also called as a supreme beggar.
Supreme beggar. Supreme beggar. Yeah.
And as you can see there's always a
serpent with him. And uh then there's
always a trident. Yeah. A pitchfork. A
trident as you could say. This is
another form of Shiva.
This form he is called as pashupati.
Pashu Pati means lord of the beasts.
He's a lord of the beasts. And um he's
also called as a horned deity by
archaeologists.
By archaeologists. Yes. Archaeologist
callar horns often. Uh so there's been
um this is called the pashupati seal. It
is in the uh Delhi museum today. It's
5,000 years old approximately according
to archaeologists and it was discovered
in the Harapan civilization site which
is actually the north and northwest part
of India. Uh Harapan civilization was
the largest ancient civilization and
advanced civilization. It's around 5,000
years old civilization. Wow.
And they found a seal and they said this
is Shiva because uh he has horns and
three faces and he's covered with
jewelry and then faces. Yeah. Another
counterfeit I think. And then his uh
feet as you can see are boine feet.
Bull feet. Bovine cow. Oh okay. So like
cow. Is that how we say cow? Like bale
or something. And it's surrounded by
animals. some animals. Yeah. And then uh
there's also goat with long horns.
The goat. I mean that that's what I'm
saying like as Christians, we just have
such an advantage knowing these symbols
of the goat and the serpent and all
these things. So again, this is 5,000y
old seal and it exists till today. And
this is Shiva.
And um it's interesting that uh they uh
you know the archaeologist said that he
was covered with jewelry. Oh, a precious
stone. Every precious stone was
discovering. Yeah. If you like this
video, like, subscribe, and hit the
notification bell so you know when we
launch new videos. And drop a comments
below and we'll try to get back to you
if we can. What?
Say that again. No. No. I don't know
what to say.
[Music]